let's check out Funko's new DC
collectible subscription box Legion Hall
of collectors so you can subscribe to
this at Legion collectors com it will
cost you twenty-five dollars comes out
every other month everything inside is
exclusive let's make this a surprise oh
so just like what the Marvel collector
for you get a pen this is Batman visa
green so we have a Superman pin here and
there is also a patch Wonder Woman patch
each month you will get a t-shirt here
check us out as I know in the past they
have had different versions shirts
randomly inserted this is Batman vs
Superman March 25th all right here we
have Batman V Superman these look like
glow-in-the-dark if Superman and Aquaman
again these are exclusive so yeah these
are probably your GV school dark okay we
also have this has been revealed we have
the armored Batman exclusive you can
check that out so there are other
figures out there you see there is a
regular armored Batman this one has
exclusive painting or coloring there's
exclusive variant cover so this is
Batman Superman number five jumbo Meyers
the dark for this so you will not be
able get this anywhere else believe that
is it inside you will find lots of BBS
Batman Superman and one role in artwork
so you can reuse the box recycle it so
that it is Funko's legion of collectors
subscription box thanks for watching let
us know what you thought of all of this
you